toer Grace was 20 when he first started
playing Eric and 27 when the show ended
the show Mostly centered around Eric and
his relationship with his friends as
they often gathered at his house more
specifically in his basement we also got
to see some major focus on Eric's
parents red and kitty who often had
major storylines that intertwined with
the' 70s kids needless to say the show
wouldn't have been the same without Eric
Foreman front and center with this
reimagined AI generated art of him as a
child he still looks like the kid who
would invite everybody over and would
continue to get more witty and sarcastic
as he grows up